was it to get Ryan to come in and okay
you know let's just talk about the can
I'll say look we after get the Deadpool
to experience was like one of my best
film experiences of my life I mean I've
had some great ones atomic blonde was
great John wick was great but Deadpool
like Ryan and I really hit it off and we
have a lot of respect for each other and
I you know came up with this idea like I
had this sort of stuffy expositional
dialogue about the virus and I had this
epiphany one night I'm like I should get
Ryan to just be the guy that gives the
mission right and gives us this
exposition because he's gonna make it
fun and so I called him and I said would
you want to do this it's I have the
scene and there's like you're the guy
CIA operative and you're giving stuff
the exposition but I know you'll come up
with something great and he's like I'm
in like I'm in Europe right now I could
come on a weekend I'll do it it'd be so
fun and I'm like great and so I sent him
the pages and he did his you know Ryan
Ryan thing and sent him back to Chris
Morgan and myself and we were really
excited and laughing and we and Dwyane
was like fired up about it as well and
it's like you could see he was gonna
start you know dig into Wayne or Dwayne
dig into Hobbs his name and like have
fun with Hobbs his masculinity and like
we were just like gonna attack turn in a
really fun way right and so that day on
set was just you know so fun and I think
even you know Dwayne and Jason had their
natural chemistry I'm sorry Dwayne and
Dwayne and Ryan had their natural
chemistry on set and it was really
nothing
Ryan had a good time doing had a good
time and so at the end of the movie when
we needed some more exposition about the
virus and what happened to it right I'm
like you love kotas you want to come
back and do a coda and he's like yeah
you know but the thing about Ryan is
like he always wants to make sure that
it's good and so we we spent the time of
like going back and forth and I thought
could it be creative and like what jokes
could we pay off from stuff
we'd set up in the in the actual movie
itself and so we went back and forth and
came up with that little game of Thrones
bit and it works great I mean I want to
see Locke carry on in this world and so
fingers crossed you know we could have
Locke and more installments of Hobbes a
cha or Locke in any standalone fast
thing he wants to do right there he's so
fun yeah completely what about Kevin
Kevin was a different I mean obviously
you know Dwayne and Kevin go way back
and they're in they're in movies it
seems like every year together yes sir
that was an easy call for him and they
were actually working together at the
time on Jumanji Jumanji or was a Jungle
Cruise area Jumanji I think it's demonic
Jumanji
so there was a conversation about you
know we have this character like a Leo
Getz type character they need to get
from one place to another they need to
access transport you know who can they
who would come in and just sort of play
this person that gets us from A to B but
makes it make it special and that was
like Bing Bing it was Kevin and we can
make the call when he makes the call I
was like I'll be there you know it's
just these really good relationships
that we had and I don't think filmmakers
get to do that that often so I'm pretty
grateful that you know we have II you
know we have these resources and these
great relationships between doing it
myself and where people wanted to show
up and just have fun for a day
sure and you know deliver something fun
for the audience come